this nasty war in nagorno-karabakh
drags on a fight over mountainous
territory populated by ethnic armenians
but which under international law
belongs to azerbaijan
with talks between the two sides
underway in moscow the azerbaijani
president tells sky news that he's ready
for a truce
but that he wants his lands back for us
it's a
patriotic war we are defending ourselves
we want to restore
our territory integrity to allow one
million refugees
to go back the battleground is not just
the autonomous region of
nagorno-karabakh
but seven azerbaijani districts around
it which armenia captured in the war in
the 1990s forcing hundreds of thousands
of azerbaijanis to flee
now when we are liberating our
territories there are video
about what's happened there everything
is destroyed
it's as if you know like stalingrad it's
even worse than stalingrad
after second world war but that is
exactly what you are doing now to the
regional capital stepanakert that is
what you are doing to
sushi which yesterday was targeted not
once but twice
a double hit on the cathedral there when
it was
very clear that civilians and
journalists were sheltering inside
that was first a provocation from
armenian side
we never did that in the past we have
armenian church in the center of baku
you can send someone or when you come
it's not as if the armenians targeted
their own cathedral how can that have
been a provocation
that's probably their provocation in
order to
present us in such a way but i can tell
you that they're shelling
our cities do you know that we have 31
killed civilians as a result of armenian
bombardment
170 wounded people
and more than 1 000 houses totally
demolished
with all due respect that is also what
you are doing with your shells on
nagorno-karabakh and you have very
sophisticated drone technology
which should allow you to see precisely
what you are targeting
so why do civilian structures keep
getting hit
no no we never attack civilians what we
did in the territory of nagorno-karabakh
we attacked the tanks we attacked their
guns
we attacked their artillery systems
and also we attacked their military
infrastructure
uh it's not our fault that this military
infrastructure sometimes is situated
in the city center in the armenian
capital today prime minister nikolan
pashinyan said he too
was ready for a truce but this conflict
dates back
three decades silencing the guns has
been done before
securing the piece has not
dinah magnus sky news moscow